s'il ne récuse pas le terme de colonie
inclusive il précise que c'est tout
simplement un centre de vacances ouvert
à toutes et tous ici on accepte tout le
monde quel que soit son orientation ou
identité sexuelle et ses choix de vie
avant d'être animateur William a eu
plusieurs expériences en colonie
lorsqu'il était adolescent s'il n'a pas
subi de discrimination personnelle il
s'est souvent senti mal à l'aise
tout était prévu pour les jeunes mais en
tant que en tant que masse en tant que
organisme en fait quand ils étaient face
aux jeunes après ils pouvaient prévoir
des activités qui correspondaient pas
aux jeunes ou par exemple des des
chambres non mixtes imposées et en fait
il prenait pas en compte par exemple les
spécificités bas de genre Thibault et
Mélina ont créé l'association toast
encolo il y a trois ans après des
expériences professionnelles dans
l'éducation populaire face à ce qu'il
considérait être des dérives mercantiles
qui conduisent à l'exclusion de certains
adolescents ils privilégie un accueil
différencié avec des règles mais aussi
une collégialité dans les décisions et
donc tout notre travail ça va être de
réfléchir localement un besoin de chaque
jeune et ça ça demande un travail assez
conséquent de s'adapter à chaque besoin
et c'est pour ça qu'on a des animes
formés et des équipes conséquentes on
est un taux d'encadrement de 1%, ce qui
est pas forcément le cas dans tous les
tous les tous les organismes
et je pense taboulé au menu du repas de
midi en partie confectionnée par les
adolescents avec les encadrants
cuisiniers et moniteurs
bienveillants ont envie de dire et très
à l'écoute et tant à l'écoute de ce
qu'on peut vivre chacun chacune mais
aussi de nos envies de de qui on est en
fait d'accord parce que cette
bienveillance est le respect des
différences ne sont pas pratiquées
partout ils sont chaque année de plus en
plus nombreux à choisir cette colonie au
cœur du Jura avec les